[Music]
how's it going bros my name is Stefano
Jesus Christ
alright this one right who the action
don't repeat it
alright I could I'm gonna leave Stefano
here because we just have to get the key
or whatever I'll put you here spawn it
okay but don't take the log lady what
what what it's Friday Friday gotta get
down on Friday boughs get the [ __ ] out
of here [ __ ] from my house barrels
hey don't longshot away from me Bell
that's what I'm talking man alright the
key is here sitting behind a freaking
spread I don't know why he makes it so
difficult way too difficult
I mean what the [ __ ] did he come from
oh my god Jesus penis I didn't deserve
that
oh no I mean Pig is that yeah hey I'm so
frickin palm pity geez guy I heard your
screaming over there was it the kind of
screaming I like maybe you know the
screaming what I feel like mine all
right that's enough piggy for today
where you going Petey
right I think I miss this justice there
before yeah it did yeah there's nothing
in it so that's found Isaac barrels it's
your fault get out of here
and I put Stefano got that I don't spit
em over here this way I got the key now
all right
I heard you're dying you set up a [ __ ]
you always die when I'm not around of
course oh you don't have to hit me Jesus
Christ
sorry Stefano all right let's follow the
ketchup it's it's no longer periods just
ketchup I don't know why I think is
obvious because if it's someone's period
then it's probably the borough's period
that means the bro is a girl and that
means he walks around and half buried
everywhere and that makes me
uncomfortable
all right oh look at this it's a P what
the [ __ ] let's night that up yeah yeah
probably hit it friggin key here and
impossible place is fine again legit
Hey two notes I am lucky dear Jenna I
heard about your plan I really hope you
will escape I saw you at the storage
picking up that Jenna you can't just
pick up hammers you are our hope oh
never mind
but since yesterday I don't hear you
anymore it's a ton of done
can we get out there Luisa found a
ladder between two rocks down here is
that it escape the problem would be
locked all right
some girls trying to escape the sack
that's lovely
ah big a what it ye look I'm Paul that's
a freaking partly okay I got to keep for
you people
hey he's figure Yi now we can real party
yeah it's Friday yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's Friday hey I found the king
thanks for piggy I know I ain't lad not
on this must be the best day of my life
just let's just go with you piggy yeah
yeah yeah yeah I heard a lot of people
like oh don't play around piggy too much
but look what you play around with PE
and you find the key yeah you like
you're like the wall that was a good a
lot of people you know impeding a lot of
people think I'm a I'm a pig I'm just
night yeah [ __ ] around okay
no just broken with the chairs broken
promises nothing in there hey coming
with me buddy yeah yeah I'm so pumped
hey this Friday can I write can you
write on me can you surf on me Pete you
can try I mean
all right Jennifer what are you doing
sleeping on my madness
Jesus oh yes come on
ah let's point terms all right I just
kept Iggy eight-year famous guy
so having fat pee you knew died what are
you talking about but you talk my bucket
of poo
I don't dare trust him I mean touch the
mat as I say all this I only got the
keys
better open all right what do we get
it's gotta be something here yeah yeah
yeah hey carpet don't scare me laughs oh
look at secret tunnels I like that hmm
can't move the mattress Oh Haunted
mattress get out of here mr. bit carpet
blocking my way
ah let's go here hello Turner yeah yeah
I Miss Piggy though I wish you could
come with me I bet even dead dug this
tunnel
all right left all right I'm just trying
to go here because I'm so fat I might
find an object nope then find [ __ ] that
was pile it's pretty cozy little Carolyn
I mean given that it is pretty dank Olli
I like that
ah a sledgehammer yay found that thing
that she talked about and stuff what is
this how the hell am I supposed to go
there are you [ __ ] kidding me huh all
right let's go back I guess I don't
really know
otherwise why we got that I'm suspecting
bad things here I'm just saying they
never make you go back in these no let's
make him go away one way or another I'm
gonna find ya
- smashes padlock oh damn
sighs so hard Matan nobody must deem
that there was a late weight it is a bit
off huh how do you bet maybe huh
nay Narracott me dick all right more
gangbang can't even enter anymore it's
very disappointing hey buddy buddy boy
oh [ __ ] I hate teleporting thank you
guys
it was you Musti I wasn't there oh my
god barrels get the [ __ ] out of here
I didn't even know anymore if they make
me find another [ __ ] key I'll swear
to [ __ ] oh come on I wish I thought
it was there hey how you doing I'm just
gonna come close and look at you
I expect oh hey a towards oh and sanny
poison that's lovely thank you very much
torso
you're welcome pity
they're really nothing they're always
something bad about these oh my god I
know it why didn't you tell me you did
not know you just stopped ah nice toys
the do something I don't know better how
to name it now it's gonna go first huh
okay go first check if it's safe it's
safe really I promise you [ __ ] liar
you tricked fit it haha I work with the
barrels Oh No get out on no why did I
even get from him I got nothing that was
completely pointless not then not then
say something do something
dance break Adam ah oh my god
teleporting naked bros alright I bet the
[ __ ] keys here I'm pissed now Peppa
oh oh oh where is he
what are you doing it battles back stop
and I was like what do you hate barrels
bTW I don't understand
like you're making them sense if I would
heat up there hey it's [ __ ] obvious
why wouldn't I hate on barrels did it
cause all the [ __ ] problems as well
all of them like there's not enough
cookies the cookies not enough barrels
like you're out of toilet paper
it's like barrels it's all there [ __ ]
sorry I'm sweating so much
thankfully you should probably should be
used to it by now
all right hey madam this is compass
chariot can we drink a pray I'll order
more do I do go far side how many ways
no one good for a discovery I don't lead
I carry the baton that's true yeah shut
up Danny thank you yeah you like that
what is the point of this why are you
just that do it something it doesn't
even react to the Sawtooths freakin
penis well it's the game there's always
a freaking key now tell me what it is
but I cut off your boss where is the key
I don't care if you can't talk to tell
me where I should keep hmm all right I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna [ __ ] it I don't
get down there buddy can I should be a
hall sending Tara Gator or something
except it didn't really get thinking in
the key so I guess this was pointless
god damn it everything is fine life
there's no more ketchup
ah sweet all right
where's that key where is dad
freaking key all right maybe I can use
this thing and put out it I don't know I
wish you could turn around I get to put
this in your attic oh I got a speech
your nipple I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
squeeze your frickin okay that's nice
enough [ __ ] around for today I mean
not for today
yeah it's Frye how the [ __ ] am I
supposed to go back I come on it's
Friday Friday Friday for beauty power
huh everybody's looking forward to this
beam stop let make a stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] box move move you will move when
I tell you to thank you no but why don't
you move buddy you were destined to move
what that's fine
I'll just hang out here all night
seriously though you think there's a bug
maybe I'm supposed to use something on
him probably with what about the lots
lots of us why we probably missed some
item by this song shot buzz he's
freaking out all right
nope did not work I would not really
surprised either but that's okay though
we need one more of these
I don't again not a freaking bugs in
this castle sorry let me go would you
let me go let me go tonight won't you
let me go let me go too all right
I am [ __ ] stuck yes that's right all
[ __ ]
daddy you get out of there - where does
that thing that I need to progress why
won't this thing move is so annoying all
right fine
will he tell me no he won't
maybe it's in here maybe I'm supposed to
climb over or something like that I mean
there was a lot of [ __ ] boxes yeah
there's a dagger there all right it's
better than the [ __ ] side just find a
key in a [ __ ] place I don't know I
prefer stuff like this because it's just
fun to climb think files get out of here
I just love climbing so much fun all
right let's push it out no you don't
think that you're too fat Jennifer all
right yeah he meant by the fire up there
just freaking heavy out now is there
something hot we get you will be there
all the second thought is probably not a
good idea to you put it in front of the
gate if I want to go back all right but
all right so I have it I do push-ups
every day I don't know push-up doesn't
relate to your arms with whatever are
you doing still doing air no one likes
you all right one more and then we
should know I'm out of stamina
I am so slow right now okay I think this
ah don't boxes are supposed to cooperate
I you're definitely not a team player
what I say one second ago boxes are
supposed to cooperate do you learn your
lesson yes pity don't hit me again I've
won more for good luck
will you learn now yes don't do it again
plate I don't care ready go all right I
guess he died and went to box heaven
finally let's do this give that over
here
I need another box what are you doing to
my box yeah stop hate when a raw barrel
is the worst thing ever
alright now it should be good
all right yeah yeah yeah look at me I'm
dancing on the line all right
stop [ __ ] around visit get together
all right all right
ah all right I'm picking up a big dagger
yeah yeah old blood-covered agate
brothers having a good time Jennifer
Jennifer are you are you doing all of
this yes pretty I'm sorry I cheated on
you that's like I said a large papaya
cresting at how the [ __ ] did we get back
here huh huh oh no I should have thought
about that I should have thrown a couple
boxes over
I got damn it this is not good I have to
climb teleport a naked guy that way are
you serious Jennifer Jennifer
talk to me Oh Oh what is that okay we
will have to be creative here all right
this goes probably pretty well on
Jennifer actually all right sweet
ah don't you dare Wow
this will be difficult no maybe it's
better if we do like this oh there's a
[ __ ] hole ha ha ha why did you tell
me all right now I'm gonna stab this
[ __ ] torso for [ __ ] up with my
life all right doesn't worry I hate you
I hate you too
stop cooperating way oh the corpse is
over here
I got a sneeze coming it's good it's
false alarm all right buddy you tell me
where the key is and I'm gonna [ __ ]
stab ya ha trick yeah I'm gonna stab you
anyway stupid oh no he's still there
what happened
oh I just dug out a key from God knows
where let's continue discussing sorry
black a bash now this problem comes
again how the hell did I go I just I
don't know what I did come on buddy
there we go yeah all right now we need
to find a locked door
I think piggy knows what it is
it's not that one isn't even here I
don't believe my mom maybe nope it's not
here where is a lock died wait what is
the key say it's for one close during
the match we need to go back no I
wouldn't call these imagined I would
call these a freakin piggy yeah yeah I'm
pumped
all right good for you is there a door I
miss nice night yeah I'm drunk yeah I
don't like you why are you class I
didn't close you tell me where the place
is
god dammit
iron maidens crying that [ __ ]
maybe you have to go back I don't know I
don't know I don't find any other doors
yeah this comes sorry's liking it right
now probably cause I'm so good at it Who
am I kidding anyway
oh I recorded 17 minutes and I really
have to upload this video cuz there was
a where's your gameplay video haha
anyway hope you enjoyed like that's not
like that's favorite like a favorite if
you enjoyed it helps a lot
subscribe to perform of road today and
I'll see you in next episode
[Music]
hello hello please don't kill me Oh No